sehr bittere tage sind das gerade für
unsere nachbarn die franzosen
zusätzlich zu corona ist auch noch der
islamistische terror zurück gestern
schon wieder messer attentate drei tote
in nizza seit der ermordung eines
lehrers der im unterricht
mohammed-karikaturen gezeigt hatte
fordert präsident makro mehr härte im
kampf gegen den islamismus und er
verteidigt die meinungsfreiheit
inklusive recht auf blasphemie wie sich
das gehört in einem freien weltlichen
land darauf ein herr erdogan so zu makro
ident in der schau dich doch erst mal
selbst irgendwie die uns wohin du dich
bewegst wie ich gestern bereits in der
stadt kayseri gesagt habe der herr ist
ein fall für den arzt er sollte sich mal
untersuchen lassen
und da guck dich doch mal selber haben
wie du aussiehst im herzen bleibt der
ergo halt ein kleiner gangster erfordert
sein volk sogar auf französische
produkte zu boykottieren ganz offiziell
der breite markt über islamismus
gesprochen und nicht über den islam
liebe zuschauer
ich möchte sie heute ausdrücklich
ermuntern ich möchte fast sagen
auffordern in den nächsten tagen und
wochen so viele französische produkte zu
kaufen wie irgend möglich weil es ist ja
alles lecker egal ob du chocolat der
gute reviews schon okay so enden rät nur
schöne flasche châteauneuf du pape
kaufen sie frankreich leer wie blöde
main das völlig ernst denn es schmeckt
super und sie ärgern diesen mann mit
jedem kauf
win win soviel dazu und wo wir gerade
bei außenpolitik sind im amerikanischen
wahlkampf im us-wahlkampf rasen die
rivalen trump und beiden auf den
showdown zu ja nächsten dienstag ist es
soweit beiden liegt zwar in allen
seriösen umfragen deutlich vorn aber das
war 2016 beihilfe ja auch so
damals als demoscope aufgehört hat ein
beruf zu sein werden wir am wahlabend
überhaupt ein klares ergebnis haben und
wie begründet ist die angst vor
bürgerkriegsähnlichen zuständen
es wird keinen bürgerkrieg geben schon
allein weil die demokraten keine waffen
haben
ohne ist zu schwer in die schlacht zu
ziehen die republikaner haben die waffen
ja alle
es wäre sicher ein sehr kurzes jetzt
wieder bürgerkriegs wochen beim mc
donald
tatsächlich gibt es in den usa längst
mehr waffen als einwohner
fakt damit punktet besonders gern im
wahlkampf mit dem second amendment also
dem recht weiße amerikaner mit
halbautomatischen waffen in die sauna zu
gehen jeder zeit und er verbreitet
natürlich weiter unbewiesene korruptions
gerüchte über seinen rivalen beiden
meine logisch mit dreck werfen ist quasi
seine kernkompetenz im schlamm ist er
einfach besser als seine gegner wie sagt
doch der bauer kämpft nicht mit dem
schwein im schlamm
es fühlt sich dort wohl eher als tun und
er ist das schwein also was ist das denn
für ein geschmackloser vergleich bei
aller liebe
schweine sind total intelligente tiere
aktuell schwäche trump in den umfragen
vor allem bei den sogenannten german
women also bei den gut situierten frauen
aus der vorstand ist eine ganz wichtige
wählergruppe inzwischen bettelte
präsident regelrecht um deren liebe
[Applaus]
ok lieb mich endlich damit gerettet
meint rammt er hat ein gesetz obamas
zurückgenommen dass minderheiten den
zugang zum wohnungsmarkt erleichtern
sollte
mit anderen worten trampert die
vorstädte weiß gehalten
undankbare vorstand weiter aber dafür
hat donald trump eine andere sehr treue
wählerschicht immer noch fest in sack
beziehungsweise im klingelbeutel mit
mehr als 60 millionen anhängern sind sie
die größte gruppe der amerikanischen
christen evangelikale ist ja gut
jesus ist doch nicht schwerhörig gott
sagenhafte 81 prozent der über 60
millionen evangelikalen haben 2016 also
bei der letzten wahl trump gewählt
vielleicht habe ich in religion nicht
richtig aufgepasst aber wir reden schon
von demselben an dem notorischen lügner
donald trump oder der hat den schwarzen
gürtel in allen sieben todsünden ist
denen egal
wir danken gott für diesen mann erst der
auserwählte gerne wirklich dass und
storage and an gott geschickt
ich weiß dass er ein kind von könig
jesus ist er wurde als ebenbild gottes
geschaffen damit von trump ist für mich
der gesalbte bestimmung dass herr
präsident geworden ist das talent der
gesalbte das einzige womit der gesamt
wird es eine bräunungscreme und von
wegen sohn von könig jesus frames vater
zur erinnerung war immobilienmakler und
sein opa hatte einen puff in kanada aber
die meinen das ernst die meinen das
ernst die evangelikale für deren kinder
gibt es sogar schon eine eigene bibel
mit wunderbaren gleichnissen wie dem vom
heiligen donald der war ein wahrer
christ und sprach lasse die kleinen
kinder aus mexiko zuge kommen auf dass
ich sie von ihren eltern trennen und in
käfige sperre dem heiligen donald war
das sakrament der ehe so heilig dass er
gleich drei mal heiratete und zwar fast
baugleiche frauen denn der herr sprach
formal das weib mit silikon zu deinem
wohlgefallen und trotzdem
frauen fand st donath noch zeit einen
gefallenen mädchen zu helfen
stormy magdalena daniels bekannt aus
filmen wie rudel booms beim pharao und
rudel booms beim pharao 2 dort gab der
dirne arbeit und weil sie davon nicht
schweigen wollte schenkte ihr 130000
silberlinge dann war ruhe brasilianer
armen jetzt mal ernsthaft wie kann man
denn auf diesem feld christen auch nur
eine sekunde lang reinfall
wenn man den konkret nach seinem glauben
fragt kommt sowas hier viel zu
persönlich mehr so viele lieblings
bibelstellen seite 12 war super 25 516
alle großartig
in wirklichkeit ist die liebe zwischen
trump und den evangelikalen ein jahr ein
taktischer deal er kriegt deren stimmen
dafür kriegen die knapp 200 stramm
konservative juristen an den
bundesgerichten die er berufen hat plus
drei neue richter am supreme court die
dann demnächst vielleicht das recht auf
abtreibung kippen
zum beispiel nur deswegen feiern die
trump gibt es die ihre präsidenten
[Musik]
warum ruft gott dafür morgens um halb
fünf an total unhöflich man schätzt rund
40 prozent der amerikaner sind anhänger
des kreationismus die glauben weder an
die evolutionslehre noch an den
menschengemachten klimawandel
dafür sind viele von denen überzeugt
dass gott unsere erde
erst vor wenigen tausend jahren
erschaffen hat reverend dennis knossalla
ein kreationistische tv prediger spricht
auf seinem youtube kanal vor bis zu 14
abonnenten referent wann genau ist die
erde entstanden ist eine gute frage und
die antwort sowie die antwort auf alle
fragen steht in diesem buch 50 shades of
grey sind geschenk für unseren bischof
hat st dieses buch die bibel die
kreationisten lesen sie als
tatsachenbericht das heißt wir können
anhand biblischer stammbäume den
zeitpunkt der schöpfung exakt datieren
und zwar das ist kein scherz auf den 23
oktober 4004 vor christus
zwei tage später wurde übrigens joe
biden geboren wird von wegen wir
christen am genom wunderbar und warum
sind so viele kreationisten glühende
trump fans ganz einfach wir hassen die
wissenschaft und deshalb wollen wir
einen präsidenten der möglichst wenig
weiß
trump ist quasi ein von gott gesamtes
leeres gefäß das für immer da leer
bleibt
ich sage immer das bisschen was man
wissen muss erfahren sehen und zum arche
noah museum in kentucky
wie alt war noah als er die arche betrag
600 jahre die menschen alten damals
anders
ja klar 600 jahre das gesundheitssystem
im heiligen land war allerdings damals
auch besser als heute in den usa
ja das glaube ich sofort in mehreren
us-staaten lehrt man diesen quark an
schulen gleichberechtigt mit der
evolutionstheorie ja aber nicht mehr
lange nach ramms wiederwahl wird darwins
lehre natürlich genauso verboten wie
diese ganzen anderen satanischen
schulfächer also physik chemie mathe und
load sprach wer aber versucht mir die
bionische formel zu erklären
dem soll das glied phantoms ferne zeit
das steht da drin sein das habe ich
improvisiert erwartet wir erleben gerade
den endkampf licht gegen dunkel
wissenschaft gegen wahrheit märz gegen
laschet und selbst corona ist doch nur
eine prüfung da hilft kein impfen
da hilft alleine beten weiter verfestigt
so witzig auf dem thron des satans
vertrauens steht im robert-koch-institut
gut finde richtig spaß
verflucht die nächste dieser krieg
donald trump will
denn die zeichen der apokalypse die
ernte verdorrt lage studios entschließen
und dann hört auf meine worte
[Musik]
ich sage dass ich weg für schrägen
nachgeht falschen keiner weise blum
keinen fall reverend davis knossalla
alter der club hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn inhaltlich stark satire comedy
gold ich habe es noch drauf also ich
würde den kanal direkt abonnieren und
auf gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das
nicht schon getan hätte das war wirklich
stark
[Musik]